>> Jessica: POLITICIANS
FLAUNTING AT GALA IN NEW YORK
CITY.
HILLARY CLINTON CALLED OUT GOING
MASKLESS AS ATTENDS TO HER GOWN.
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR ERIC ADAMS
SPORTING A END GUN VIOLENCE
TUXEDO.
KIM KARDASHIAN SPARKLING
$5 MILLION DRESS THAT MARILYN
MONROE PRESIDENT JOHN F.
KENNEDY.
GREG, WOULD YOU LIKE TO COMMENT
ON KIM KARDASHIAN'S DRESS?
>> Brian: I COULDN'T BELIEVE DID
YOU SEE WHAT KILMEADE WORE?
UNBELIEVABLY SHOWED SO MUCH SKIN
DISGUSTING.
>> Dana: WORKING OUT.
>> Greg: PEOPLE WHO LIKE TO
DEFINE THEMSELVES EDGY
REBELLIOUS OR WHATEVER.
THEY LOVE TO STAND OUT BUT THEY
JUST HAVE SO MUCH A DESPERATE
NEED TO BELONG WHEN ONE OF THESE
EVENTS HAPPEN DRESSED UP AND
OBEY AND FORM TO THE COLLECTIVE
NEED TO BE SCENE.
IT'S LIKE YOU DON'T NEED TO GO
TO THESE THINGS IT'S LIKE THIS
IS REPLACING THE OSCARS AND
SOMEBODY TELLS THEM HE THEIR
PUBLICIST SAYS YOU HAVE TO BE
SEEN.
HILLARY IN A DRESS WITH THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN OR THE BLACK
GENTLEMAN IN THE MASK HOLDING
HER SKIRT OR HER TRAIN, I MEAN
THAT'S THE HIERARCHY THAT'S THE
STRUCTURE THAT MAKES THE ELITES
HAPPY.
YOU FOLLOW THE RULES.
THEY DON'T HAVE.
TO SAY YOU ARE DOWN THERE, I'M
UP HERE.
>> Jessica: JOEY, DO YOU THINK
THE AVERAGE PERSON WHO MIGHT
HAVE CAUGHT A GLIMPSE OF THIS
AND OBVIOUSLY LAST NIGHT THIS
WAS NOT THE BIG NEWS STORY WITH
THE ABORTION CASE LEAK, DO YOU
THINK THAT'S HOW THEY FEEL ABOUT
THIS OR THEY JUST THINK THIS IS
WHAT RICH PEOPLE DO?
>> Joey: I THINK THE AVERAGE
PERSON ACCIDENT KNOW WHAT THE
MET GALA IS.
IS IT IF YOU HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
TO GO DRESSED AS "STAR WARS"
CHARACTER DO IT.
I DON'T CONDEMN ANY OF THIS.
WHAT I CONDEMN SAME PEOPLE
WALKING A BLOCK OVER THE NEXT
DAY AND HOLDING SOME PRESS
RELIEF HOW WE HAVE TO TAX THE
RICH.
BE A LITTLE BIT CONSISTENT AND
LITTLE BIT LESS OF A HYPOCRITE
AND WE WILL GET ALONG JUST FINE.
I KNOW SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE NOT
VERY WELL AND I DON'T REALLY
CARE IF THEY HAD A GOOD TIME AND
DRESSED UP AND LOOK LIKE IDIOTS
FOR A NIGHT AND CALLED IT
FASHION.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT THAT AT ALL.
I CARE ABOUT WHAT THEY TELL ME
WHAT I SHOULD DO WITH MY MONEY
OR ELON MUSK WHAT HE SHOULD DO
WITH HIS MONEY.
THAT'S THE HYPOCRISY OF IT ALL.
WE EXPECT DEMOCRATS TO DO
DEMOCRAT THINGS I GUESS.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> Jessica: YOU DON'T KNOW THAT
WAS YOUR FINAL WORD.
DANA?
>> Dana: ONE OF THE WORST THINGS
HAPPEN TO ME IS TO BE INVITED TO
THAT THING.
I WOULD CRINGE THE ENTIRE TIME.
I WOULD MAKE GREG GO WITH ME SO
WE COULD MAKE SOME FUN.
>> Greg: COSTUME PAIR I THINK
IT'S FUNNY THAT THE MET GALA
ALWAYS FOLLOWS THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENCE DINNER.
IT'S PERFECT.
I'M SURE THAT EVERYBODY THERE
REALLY TRULY BELIEVES THAT RICH
PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE THEIR STUDENT
LOANS PAID OFF.
I'M SURE THAT WAS A HIGH TOPIC
OF CONVERSATION.
>> Greg: THE GIANT MET.
>> Joey: I WILL GO WHEN I CAN
AFFORD NICKEL PLATED LEGS.
>> Judge Jeanine: I DON'T
BEGRUDGE THEM DOING THIS WHAT DO
I BEGRUDGE SOMETIMES I THINK THE
MAYOR SPENT MORE TIME ENDING GUN
VIOLENCE IN TERMS OF MAKING THAT
SUIT AND PUTTING IT ON THAN HE
HAS IN ACTUALLY TRYING TO END
GUN VIOLENCE BECAUSE WHEN HE
WENT TO ALBANY.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO ANSWER HOW HE
FAILED IN ALBANY.
ELON MUSK BROUGHT HIS MOTHER NOW
I LOVE HIM EVEN MORE.
LET THEM DO THEIR THING.
THEY ARE HAPPY WITH THEMSELVES.
GOOD FOR THEM.
WHO CARES?
>> Jessica: HIS MOM WOULD YOU
SAY USED TO BE A SUPERMODE